What is space time?
You already know.
You have never met
someone at a place
unless it was also at a time.
You have never met someone
at a time unless it was--
OK, I get it.
I get it.
So we--
Whoa, well, wait a minute.
What happens to a photon
from 13 billion 0.800
million years that comes
this way and enters
my eye so I can see it?
Where's space involved in that?
It entered your eye at a
time and at a place right here.
That's all that matters here.
Is that all we're saying?
Well, once you have
formalized space and time
and know that they're
conjoined, then
you can make all kinds of
fascinating calculations
with relativity.
Well, what is all
that the train's going
and I'm walking down there.
- Exactly!
I'm walking down the train.
I'm walking on--
And the time change.
And the time is
going to change.
What is all that?
That's all the consequences
of thinking about space and time
as conjoined.
But it's confusing.
So?
And not only is it--
The universe is under
no obligation to make
sense to William Shatner.
OK?
No, but William Shatner's
under the obligation
to make sense of the
universe, as you are doing.
And why do I slow down as I
approach the speed of light?
It doesn't apply to
a photon 13 billion--
No.
You want to freak out?
I don't want your
head to explode.
You ready?
- Yeah.
- OK.
- No, you're not ready.
Are you ready?
- No, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
- OK, OK.
The faster you go,
the slower time ticks.
Say that again.
The faster you move, the
slower time ticks for you
as seen by others.
Right.
As you approach
the speed of light,
time continues to slow down.
WILLIAM SHATNER: Yes.
At the speed of
light, time stops.
Which means for a photon moving
at the speed of light, when it
is absorbed in
your retina, it is
the same instant it was
emitted at the Big Bang
14 billion years ago.
That's what I thought.
The photon gets emitted.
Bam!
As far as it's concerned,
it is in your eye
in that same instant.
Can we measure that
photon and observe--
Yes!
WILLIAM SHATNER: --the Big Bang?
I know that that came from the
Big Bang, and I'm watching it.
And it's taken 13.8
billion years to reach you.
But if you are that
photon, it does
not experience that time delay.
What a great
science fiction story.
That--
Instantaneous.
[applause]